today we're going to be taking a look at
one of the otter scps in the
foundation's custody the foundation has
plenty of weird and downright silly
anomalies as we've covered extensively
in the past plenty of them are objects
that you wouldn't imagine need to be
under heavy containment but you'd be
wrong even innocuous household objects
with a harmless albeit annoying anomaly
can pose an immense danger to normalcy
and human life so today we're going to
be taking a look at
scp-2966
affectionately and nervously referred to
by scientists on break and at the water
cooler with an odd nickname the infinite
tp tp of course refers to exactly what
you're thinking of toilet paper just
based off that nickname you've probably
already gotten a pretty good idea of
what this anomaly is but you'd be
surprised just because something is
predictable doesn't mean it's harmless
or easy to contain
scp-2966 is contained at outpost 117 a
small isolated little facility far far
out in the icy tundras of northern
canada well away from any other
settlements or foundation sites it's
kept so far away because of any other
scp objects coming into contact with
scp-2966
is incredibly dangerous and prohibited
under any circumstances it's also kept
so far away from cities or towns for
another reason below the ground outpost
117 is host to an experimental thorium
nuclear reactor thorium reactors are
highly efficient nuclear reactors but
only a few exist in the entire world for
scientists to perform research on what's
one doing under a tiny out of the way
facility in the canadian wilderness well
all nuclear reactors produce a lot of
heat and energy as they're designed to
this reactor is right next to the
containment chamber
scp-2966 is locked in pumping heat into
the chamber at incredibly high
temperatures
scp-2966 can only be removed for
experimentation study or cleaning when
enough heat has been pumped into the
chamber to heavily reduce how much
matter there is but the scp foundation
is in the business of containing
anomalies not destroying them like the
goc
why would they be using nuclear power to
slowly and constantly degrade what seems
like a fairly innocuous anomaly well
clearly it's not entirely innocuous
outpost 117 staff is as bare bones as
the facility itself only a single
skeleton crew of 16 people just enough
to keep the facility and its reactor up
and running without risking any
casualties three nuclear engineers
trained in the upkeep of nuclear
reactors and four foundation researchers
to monitor the reactor and
scp-2966 containment chamber along with
that there are eight trained soldiers
from the foundation's mtfs to guard the
facility and its perimeter 25 kilometers
out from the outpost itself but that's
only 15 people who's the 16th well
unsurprisingly it's a d-class subject to
be used for direct experimentation with
the anomaly considering most scp sites
have personnel counts in the hundreds or
even thousands 16 seems remarkably
little but the foundation has learned
their lesson from past breach events
involving scp-2960
the d-class in the orange jumpsuit has
an extremely important job every eight
hours three times a day the d-class is
to use as cp 2966
given what we know the anomaly is you
can imagine what that entails but
whenever it is used at least 10 sheets
of toilet paper have to be removed from
it and well used that use is heavily
monitored by the research team and a few
of the mtf troopers and radio
communication is maintained through the
whole gross event the research team
advises the d-class on whether to speed
up or slow down the rate at which they
tear off paper from scp-2966
there's other equipment too a vast array
of sensors and scales to measure
scp-2966 mass and density and the data
is fed back to the researchers and into
the nuclear reactor systems needless to
say all of this is extremely strange
what could a role of tp infinite as it
may be possibly due to warrant a
dedicated research team and nuclear
reactor not to mention regular use
experiments and constant monitoring of
its data points whatever it is it is
dangerous the foundation is currently
constructing a runway for jet aircraft
just outside of outpost 117 so that
personnel can evacuate should something
go critical not the nuclear reactor but
scp-2966
clearly whatever it can do it is more
worrisome than a nuclear reactor going
into meltdown we've got a lot of
questions by now so let's see if we can
figure out what exactly as cp2966
does our predictions from the name
however were entirely accurate
scp-2966 is an anomalous branded role of
toilet paper for security reasons we
can't tell you the brand but we can tell
you that it's entirely possible as cp
2966 might have a distant cousin in your
own bathroom the first strange thing
about scp-2966
is its weight it weighs at least several
kilograms though its weight is usually
changing and foundation personnel are
told not to try reducing it not after
the incident anyway it sticks around
five and a half kilograms you'll notice
that it's a lot heavier than you'd
expect a toilet paper roll to be given
it's made of well paper its weight isn't
the only unusual thing about it it's
also really good toilet paper
anomalously good even we won't go into
detail because i don't think anyone
wants the details on that but let's just
say the best toilet paper you've ever
used
scp-2966 is softer stronger better in
every way but once a sheet is ripped out
of
scp-2966 role it's not anomalous anymore
it can be used and thrown away normally
scp-2966 itself is attached to the wall
inside a metal housing the kind you'd
see in a public bathroom with no way to
remove or replace it not that it needs
to be replaced x-rays and ultrasounds of
the metal housing are inconclusive but
the foundation doesn't want to cut into
it with saws because well you'll see not
to mention the fact that the metal
housing is the main way the reactor's
heat is funneled into scp-2966
and playing with nuclear power is a
little risky but what's actually
anomalous about scp-2966
well it's an infinite roll of toilet
paper but we knew that already since
scp-2966 was contained at least 10
kilometers of toilet paper have been
pulled from it over six miles the
research team hasn't seen any evidence
of it absorbing mass or producing new
toilet paper and testing has revealed
it's not pulling the paper from an
alternate dimension or reality despite
all the testing the researchers are
baffled by how exactly scp-29
keeps producing the toilet paper that it
does but even if they don't understand
how it happens they have gained a pretty
good understanding of what the results
are and the results are a lot less fun
than you might think
see
scp-2966 still obeys the first law of
thermodynamics matter and energy can't
be created or destroyed only change
forms so
scp-2966 doesn't actually create toilet
paper so much as it absorbs energy from
its surroundings then transforms that
energy into matter more specifically
toilet paper how exactly it absorbs
energy is unclear to the foundation but
they've run the math one sheet of
scp-2966 weighs approximately 3 grams
which means that approximately 2.04
times 10 to the 16th joules of energy or
roughly 65 tons of tnt is needed for one
sheet of
scp-2966 to be produced from there they
were able to extrapolate that scp-2966
contains at least several thousand
sheets within the role an extremely
extremely large amount of explosive
power all contained in a roll of toilet
paper now you get why
scp-2966 is so dangerous it's not just a
roll of toilet paper in the wrong hands
it could be one of the most powerful
explosives ever detonated easily able to
wipe out half a country but if you think
that's where
scp-2966 danger really lies think again
removing scp-2966
sheets is harmless until you remove 10
of them at a time then it'll start
absorbing the energy around it at
roughly the rate that the sheets are
removed it's trying to rapidly gain
energy to rebuild itself and it'll get
the energy from anything it's usually in
the form of heat energy but it will
absorb anything even sound but when
there's no active source of power
scp-2966 becomes dangerous it starts
sucking up energy from the ambient heat
around it and given the large amount of
energy it sucks up fast in only a few
minutes it can bring the temperature of
the room it's in to absolute zero
completely stopping all molecular
activity this has happened twice when
the power went out at outpost 117 both
times the casualties were high research
personnel sacrificed themselves to run
into
scp-2966 chamber and start ripping
sheets away from it bringing the
temperature down they all died from
hypothermia but they saved the entire
site and stopped
scp-2966 from going critical you see
when
scp-2966 isn't used for a while it
starts to decay the matter it's gained
in the form of toilet paper is reduced
back into pure energy radiation
thankfully it's not ionizing radiation
the kind you'd find in a nuclear bomb
it's simple heat and alpha radiation
mostly harmless if you're equipped right
after extensive testing and more than a
little trial and error the researchers
figured out the perfect distance between
using
scp-2966 after letting it absorb energy
and letting it decay into radiation
eight hours that's why the d-class has
to use scp-2966
every eight hours because if it goes
over something very bad happens
scp-2966 decays matter and energy
exponentially and gets faster and faster
the longer it's left untouched within a
day and a half
scp-2966 goes critical at which point
the rate of energy radiation gets so
high that it starts rapidly getting
close to infinity sounds like a lot of
complicated physics right so let's bring
it down to terms all of us will
understand when the rate of energy decay
becomes infinite what happens is that
scp-2966
entire mass is converted into energy in
a single moment all that energy
stockpile is released in one gigantic
titanic explosion remember how we
mentioned that
scp-2966 could feasibly be used as a
bomb yeah this is that bomb exploding
the explosion would result in at least 1
000 megatons of tnt for comparison the
tsar bomba the soviet mother of all
bombs had a yield of about 50 megatons
needless to say
scp-2966 going critical and exploding
would very likely be an xk-class
doomsday event aside from blowing up
half of canada it would cause wildfires
tsunamis and easily blanket the sky in
ash and soot choking out plant life and
that's all aside from the massive human
casualties the foundation has long since
realized that even though outpost 117 is
out of the way
scp-2966 going off would be much much
more than even they could handle thus
the containment procedures currently in
place keep
scp-2966 right in the sweet spot so that
it doesn't need to absorb energy from
people but make sure it doesn't get
enough energy that it decides today is a
great day to extinguish human life as we
know it when
scp-2966 was being used by the d-class
they noticed something a little odd the
d-class from the toilet on their radios
reported that the room temperature of
the containment chamber seemed to drop a
little the researchers aren't quite sure
of what this means yet but the d-class
also reported that the paper removed
from scp-2966
is exceptionally comfortable strong and
effective as toilet paper a handful of
the researchers submitted a proposal to
remove sheets of toilet paper from
scp-2966
and re-roll them to send to other
foundation facilities but due to the
risk and possibility of accidentally
creating another scp-2966
the council denied it out of hand so now
we've got a much better understanding of
what the heck scp-2966
is and how a little roll of toilet paper
could pose such a massive overwhelming
threat to not just the foundation but
all human life and why the containment
procedures are as extensive and thought
out as they are the research teams at
outpost 117 are hard at work performing
additional research on scp-2966
but there are still big questions most
importantly how was this thing created
who created it and how did the
foundation get a hold of it and learn
what it could do without accidentally
detonating it well
scp-2966 was discovered after global
weather satellites noticed the
temperature dropping in a small part of
the canadian wilderness the foundation
being tapped into the global information
network also noticed and realized the
temperature drop was anomalous agents in
the area confirmed that something
strange was going on in mobile task
force theta 19 the rocketeers found a
small research facility named pine range
research out in the backwoods but that
wasn't the strange part the strange part
was how it was completely frozen over
for an entire square kilometer despite
it being a warm summer day the mtf
measured the temperature then rechecked
it three more times to ensure they
hadn't gone insane
the temperature was negative 108 degrees
celsius for comparison the coldest
temperature ever recorded on earth was
negative 90 degrees celsius the research
team are now able to say that the only
reason everything wasn't at absolute
zero was because the breach had happened
hours ago and the sun had time to warm
everything up a little the mobile task
force breached into the building and
found a scene of devastation all
individuals in the building had been
killed from hypothermia and exposure as
they went further in they encountered a
lecture hall with one researcher giving
a lecture to others holding scp-2966
because
scp-2966 had completely frozen
everything all the electronics in the
building were corrupted and the
foundation couldn't get any useful data
but the mtf did discover a handwritten
journal by the researcher in one of the
offices and was able to recover small
sections of text after thawing it the
journal was a small diary of research
notes and daily happenings from the
researcher it detailed how the pine
range research company had achieved a
huge breakthrough in toilet paper
technology their new highly effective
toilet paper formula was somehow
infinite the company had been
experimenting with anomalies they
planned to monetize the product and even
expand into other paper products but a
few weeks later the researcher detailed
how the project had hit what he called a
minor setback they weren't able to
produce cellulose fibers making up the
paper fast enough to make the roll truly
infinite it would eventually run out
before restocking itself but he had a
solution in mind though it was rare and
expensive using a halved isotope of the
element hafnium known as quarternium
though the foundation hasn't been able
to find any other evidence of such an
element the researcher admitted that he
was a botanist not a physicist or
chemist but he was perfectly capable of
understanding the research papers
written by his colleagues on the matter
he claimed that in this day and age
anyone with a doctorate should be able
to understand others work if they wrote
it clearly enough he was dead set on
figuring out a way to make his project
work and work it did the very next entry
detailed how a metallic housing of the
toilet paper was complete the initial
roll of toilet paper had been added in
and soon the quarter neon alloy would be
complete for insertion into something
called the hyperbaric containment field
they were still running into issues here
and there particularly on the matter of
the radiation that it was constantly
emitting but the researcher was
confident that they wouldn't hamper the
rest of the design unfortunately from
the frost damage the remainder of that
entry was rendered illegible another
entry the foundation was able to recover
from the journal was dated to the day
before they encountered the temperature
drop in the canadian interior the
researcher wrote about how the energy
required for the production of radiation
and from it the toilet paper was higher
than he expected it to be from his
calculations but he wasn't worried and
planned to rework the calculations
slightly differently he didn't have time
to walk it back for more extensive
testing and modeling since the first
test of the prototype was tomorrow from
what the entry read he was excited that
the world would never again need toilet
paper the rest of that page was filled
with equations only some of which the
foundation were able to decipher but the
foundation mathematicians discovered
what went wrong when they solved the
equations by themselves the researcher
had made a very simple error early on
when calculating e equals m c squared
which led to his entire work being
thrown off and coming to a conclusion
that the energy output wouldn't nearly
be as high of course the researcher was
tragically and fatally incorrect his
desire to save the world from toilet
paper shortages might have been
prescient given current events but his
lack of care and patience led to the
deaths of him and all of his co-workers
and the creation of scp-2966
the foundation moved in and suppressed
the event with a cover story of a burst
liquid nitrogen tank and amnestics were
disseminated to any local witnesses
since the foundation couldn't safely
move scp-2966
they chose to convert pine range
research to outpost 117 and contain it
where it was but
scp-2966 story isn't quite done yet
remember how i mentioned that foundation
personnel aren't allowed to try reducing
scp-2966's weight since the incident
well a few months after
scp-2966 was contained an experiment was
performed to see if
scp-2966's mass could be reduced if they
pumped it full of energy while rapidly
removing sheets but
scp-2966 immediately went critical and
exploded albeit with a much lower yield
than if it had been fully energized
outpost 117 was completely destroyed and
all the staff were killed though no
civilians were harmed but in the smoking
crater as cp 2966 was recovered unharmed
and significantly lighter though the
foundation has rebuilt outpost 117 and
recontained scp-2966
they've learned that simply letting it
explode by itself is not a solution this
toilet paper just won't quit now go
check out
scp-1984 dead hand and scp-186 to end
all wars for more explosive anomalies
from scp explained